>> Tucker: WE KNOW A LOT OF
AFGHAN REFUGEES ARE COMING HERE.
HOW MANY EXACTLY, WHERE ARE THEY
GOING, HOW ARE THEY BEING
PROCESSED WHEN THEY GET HERE?
WE HAVE ANSWERS TO SOME OF THOSE
QUESTIONS TONIGHT.
HERE'S WHAT WE LEARNED.
FROM GOVERNMENT SOURCES.
DALLAS AIRPORT RIGHT OUTSIDE
WASHINGTON IS A MAIN WELCOMING
SITE FOR FLIGHTS LANDING AT ALL
HOURS OF THE DAY.
AS OF THIS MORNING, 3,700 MEN
FROM AFGHANISTAN WERE PROCESSED.
ONE REASON IT LANDED THERE WITH
NEARLY 200 EVACUEES.
HOMELAND SECURITY OFFICIALS
DISCUSSING OPENING SIMILAR SITES
AT OTHER AIRPORTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
DHS HAS ALSO BEEN SOLICITING
VOLUNTEERS OVERSEAS.
CURRENTLY THREE OF THOSE VETTING
REFUGEES IN BAHRAIN, QATAR, AND
THERE ARE MANY.
ALSO OPEN OVER 400.
DHS IS GOAL IS TO PROCESS 10,000
REFUGEES EVERY DAY AND MANY OF
THESE OVERSEAS LOCATIONS SO WE
REACHED OUT FOR COMMENT ON THE
FRIDAY AND A SPOKESMAN SAID THEY
ARE "WORKING "WORKING AROUND THE
CLOCK TO ENSURE INDIVIDUALS ARE
SCREENED PRIOR TO ARRIVING IN
THE U.S. AND UPON ARRIVAL.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO HAD NO
IDEA OF THE WERE GOING TO TAKE
KABUL AND THE WEEKEND.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN?
THEIR ATTITUDES, A LOT OF GOOD
PEOPLE BUT VERY DIFFERENT FROM
THOSE OF MOST AMERICANS.
A NEW POLL FOUND THAT 99% OF
AFGHAN MUSLIMS SUPPORT ENACTING
SHARIA LAW.
SO MANY REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THIS AT
ALL.
IN FACT, SOME OF THOSE ONE IS TO
EVACUATE AFGHANS BEFORE WE GET
ALL AMERICANS CITIZENS OUT OF
THE COUNTRY.
ONE OF THOSE REPUBLICANS NOT
SURPRISINGLY IS BEN SASSE OF
NEBRASKA.
THE SINGLE GUILTY AS THE WHITE
MAN IN AMERICA.
HE SAID WHEN YOU TAKE IT A